[Musique]
le para o qui est
il ya un demi siècle c'est une simple
ligue de garage avec de l'équipement
improvisé
aujourd'hui les joueurs sont puissants
et agile le sport et ans et plus
spectaculaire que jamais
[Applaudissements]
1976 la suède profite des premiers jeux
paralympiques d'hiver pour promouvoir
une invention locale une luge modifié
qui peut servir autant au patinage de
vitesse qu à qui
quand le para ok deviennent disciplines
officielles la luge est encore lourde et
les lames plutôt espacées
les joueurs doivent s'incliner pour
prendre des virages avant de retomber
sur nos repas 4
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui l'écart entre les lames et
d'à peine quelques millimètres et comme
elles sont arrondis la zone de contact
avec la glace est minime
ce qui rend la luge plus facile à
manoeuvrer
[Applaudissements]
avec cette luge un joueur peut se
faufiler entre des adversaires ou faire
demi tour en 1 kader une agilité
remarquable qui exige un équilibre et
une force hors du commun
à mesure que le sport se développe la
technique se raffine
en particulier la propulsion
pour mettre à profit tous ses muscles
l'athlète incline de torse et tire les
bras et frappe la glace avec une force
de 2 à 3 fois son poids
[Musique]
en tenant le bâton en diagonale l'impact
se produit près du centre de gravité le
gros de l'effort se fait donc en poussée
notamment grâce au tri set quand un
joueur immobile seiler la cadence
dépasse les deux compartiments
[Applaudissements]
en échappée il doit aussi contrôler la
rondelle et tout en maintenant les
équilibres saisir l'autre bout du bâton
armé le bras et utiliser son poignet
pour projeté la rondelle dans les airs à
plus de 100 kilomètres à l'heure
dans ce sport chaque athlète est unique
chaque luge fait sur mesure
mais ce qui unit les joueurs canadiens
c'est le plaisir de jouer et surtout
leur rivalité avec les américains
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]